CYNTHIA THOMAS: Hi there.
We're back with "What's
New In Networking,"
this time for Anthos
and compute networking.
We've got some important GKE
features to help you scale.
I'm Cynthia Thomas, and I want
to catch you up on the latest,
so stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We have lots of new updates
for GKE to help you scale,
as well as compute
networking, so let's dive in.
First, let's start with the
GKE L4 ILB subsetting feature.
Prior to this feature,
the internal load balancer
was limited to 250 nodes
for backends for the ability
to health check
and load balance.
GKE operators found it difficult
to deploy services to scale,
namely load balancers
for large clusters.
This meant that workarounds
had to be explored
and additional operational
overhead was required.
Now with GKE L4
ILB subsetting, you
can deploy large
services on clusters
beyond the 250-node
limit without worrying
about any operational overhead.
GKE clusters can now
scale to thousands
without any load balancer
or networking constraints.
Additionally, we
removed the constraints
on port count usage, too.
Onto the next feature to help
you scale GKE deployments,
multi-pod CIDRs.
I know some of you have
mentioned to me or my teammates
that you need more
flexibility in assigning
IP ranges to GKE clusters.
Well, we hear you, and we've
been implementing features,
like flexible pod
CIDRs per node,
the use of non-RFC1918
addressing,
and now we present to
you multi-pod CIDRs.
I know it can be a struggle
with your private IP
space, especially
those of you coming
from already-fragmented
IP assignments
in your environments.
We all wish it was easy to
find large CIDRs and move
workloads to new,
larger clusters,
but it's not always realistic.
Well, multi-pod CIDRs let
you grow your clusters
by adding node pools
with additional subnets,
and you'll have the
sizing of your choice.
Now you don't have to worry
about recreating clusters
and migrating the workloads.
Just add a node pool
with a multi-post CIDR
and you're good.
You don't have to worry about
having a large contiguous IP
block for your Kubernetes pods.
Next, more awesomeness
for GKE clusters,
combining your managed
Kubernetes clusters
with the highly available
and highly scalable
managed DNS by
Google, Cloud DNS.
This is special
because it brings
a container-native
integration with Cloud DNS,
meaning your headless
and cluster IP services
are discoverable via Cloud DNS.
This means you don't need
to rely on an in-cluster DNS
service like kube-dns.
For those who aren't
familiar, Cloud DNS
is a globally
distributed DNS service
managed by Google that scales to
millions of queries per second.
You get all the
operational goodness
of Cloud DNS, like DNS query
logging and monitoring,
with Kubernetes' service
and pod resolution
done outside of the cluster.
Our last update
on GKE networking
is about DNS for
multi-cluster services.
You can now expose
a headless service
and have an A record
for each backend pod.
This means one pod can
speak to a specific pod
within the multi-cluster
services topology,
referable by hostname.
This enables the
full implementation
of the Kubernetes
multi-cluster DNS spec.
Our final update
for this episode
is related to
compute networking.
You can now bring your
own IPs to Google Cloud
and take advantage
of Google networking,
meaning you can bring your
purchased public IPv4 addresses
and use them for your
Google Cloud resources,
while Google worries
about the global route
advertisements for you.
Yep, that's right.
You can take advantage of our
networking with your own IPs,
and we manage them like we
manage Google-provided IPs.
Once we've validated
that you own the IPs,
you can use them like any
static external IP-- so
attach them to VMs, Cloud
NAT, or a Google Cloud load
balancer.
We can also assist
with the process
through a live migration
when part of the prefix
is already being advertised.
Thanks for joining me today in
getting up-to-date on the GKE
features that will
help you scale
and for Bring Your Own
IP to Google Cloud.
You've got the links
below in the description
so you can go straight to the
docs for these new features.
And make sure you subscribe
to the Google Cloud Tech page.
Thanks for watching
"What's New In Networking."
Until next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]